in a substack blog post titled what the
is eak or actually what the fstar
is eak you write strategically speaking
we need to work towards several
overarching civilization goals that are
all
interdependent and the four goals are
increase the amount of energy we can
harness as a
species climb the CF gradient in the
short term this almost certainly means
nuclear fion
increase human flourishing via Pro
population growth policies and pro eonic
growth
policies create artificial general
intelligence the single greatest Force
multiplier in human history and finally
develop interplanetary and Interstellar
transport so that Humanity can spread
beyond the Earth could you build on top
of that to maybe
say what to you is the eak movement what
are the goals what are the
principles the goal is for the human
techn capital mimetic machine to become
self-aware and to hypatius engineer its
own growth so let's let's DEC each of
those uh words so you have humans you
have technology you have capital and
then you have you have memes information
right and all of those systems are
coupled with one another right humans
work at companies they acquire inal
capital and humans communicate via memes
and information propagation um and our
goal was to have a sort of viral
optimistic movement that is aware of how
the system works a fundamentally it
seeks to grow and we simply want to lean
into the natural tendencies of the
system to adapt for its own growth um so
in that way you write the ex is
literally a mimetic optimism virus that
is constantly drifting mutating and
propagating in a decentralized fashion
so mimetic optimism virus so you do want
it to be a virus to to maximize the
spread and uh is hypatius therefore the
optimism will incentivize its
growth we see eak as a sort of um metah
huris a a sort of very thin uh cultural
framework from which you can have much
more opinionated Forks right
fundamentally we just say that it's good
the SI what got us here is
this adaptation of the whole system you
know based on thermodynamics and that
process is good and we should keep it
going right that is the core thesis
everything else is okay how how do we
ensure that uh we maintain this
malleability and adap ability well
clearly not suppressing variance uh and
and and maintaining uh free speech
freedom of thought Freedom of
Information
propagation and freedom to do AI
research is important for us to converge
the fastest on the space of uh
Technologies ideas and whatnot that lead
to this growth um and so ultimately you
know there's been quite a few Forks some
are just memes but some are more serious
right vitalic butterin recently made a
diac fork he has his own sort of
fine-tunings of iak does anything jump
out to memory of the unique
characteristic of that fork from vitalic
I would say that it's it's trying to
find a middle ground between eak and
sort of EA and AI safety to me like
having a movement that is opposite to
what was the mainstream narrative that
was taking over silicon value was
important to sort of shift the dynamic
range of opinions and you know it's it's
like the balance between centralization
and decentralization the real Optimum is
always somewhere in the middle right uh
but but for eak we're pushing for
entropy novelty disruption malleability
speed uh rather than being like sort of
conservative suppressing thought
suppressing speech adding constraints
adding too many regulations slowing
things down and so it's kind of we're
trying to bring balance to the force
right
systems balanced to the force human
civilization yeah it's literally the
forces of constraints versus the
entropic force that makes us explore
right systems are optimal when they're
at the edge of criticality between Order
and Chaos right between
constraints um energy minimization and
entropy right systems want to
equilibrate balance these two things and
so I thought that the balance was
lacking and so we created this movement
to to bring balance well I like how I I
like the sort of visual of the last Cape
of ideas evolving through Forks soort of
kind
of thinking on the other part of
History uh thinking of uh Marxism as the
original repository and then Soviet
communism is a fork of that and then the
maoism is a fork of the of Marxism and
communism so those are all Forks they're
exploring different ideas thinking of
culture almost like code right nowadays
I mean you're what you prompt and the LM
or what you put in the constitution of
an LM is is is basically its cultural
framework what it believes right um and
uh you can share it on GitHub nowadays
so starting trying to take inspiration
from what has worked in the sort of uh
machine of uh software uh to adapt over
the space of code could we apply that to
culture and our goal is to not say you
should live your life this way XYZ is to
H is to set up a process where people
are always searching over subcultures
and competing for M share and I think
creating this malleability of culture is
super important for us to converge onto
the cultures and the heuristics about
how to live one's life that are updated
to to modern times because there's
really been a a sort of vacuum of of
spirituality and culture people don't
feel like they belong to any one group
and there's been parasitic ideologies
that have taken up opportunity to to
populate this pach dish of of Minds
right uh Elon calls it the Mind virus um
we call it the the D Cel M virus complex
which is a decelerative that is kind of
the the overall pattern between all of
them there's many variants as well um
and so you know if there's a sort of
viral pessimism decelerative Movement we
needed to have not only one movement uh
but you know many many variants so it's
very hard to pinpoint and stop but the
overarching thing is nevertheless a kind
of uh M medic optimism
pandemic so uh I mean okay let me ask
you do you think eak to some degree is a
cult Define
cult I think a lot of human progress is
made when you have independent thought
so you have individuals that are able to
think freely
and very
powerful uh mimetic systems can kind of
lead to group think there's something in
human nature that leads to like Mass
hypnosis Mass hysteria we start to think
alike whenever there's a sexy idea that
captures our minds and so it's actually
hard to like break us apart like pull us
apart diversify thought so I'm to that
degree to to which degree is everybody
kind of chanting eak eak like the sheep
and Animal Farm well first of all it's
fun it's rebellious right like uh you
know
many um I I I think we lean into there
there there's this concept of sort of
meta irony right of of sort of being on
the boundary of like we're not sure if
they're serious or not and it's it's
much more playful and much more fun
right like um for example we talk about
thermodynamics being our God right um
and sometimes we do cult-like things but
there's no like ceremony and and robes
and whatnot uh not yet
uh but ultimately yeah I I mean I
totally agree that it seems to me that
humans want to feel like they're part of
a group so they naturally try to agree
with their neighbors and and find common
ground and and that leads to sort of
mode collapse in the space of ideas
right we used to have sort of one
cultural uh Island that was allowed it
was a typical Subspace of thought and
anything that was diverting from that
sub space of thought was suppressed or
you were cancelled right now we've
created a new mode but the whole point
is that we're not trying to have very
restricted space of thought there's not
just one way to think about eak and its
many forks and and the point is that
there are many forks and there can be
many clusters in many islands and I
shouldn't be in control of it uh in any
way uh I mean there's no formal org uh
whatsoever uh I just put out uh tweets
and and uh certain BL blog posts and
people are free to defect and Fork if
there's an aspect they don't like and so
that makes it so that there should be a
sort of deter deterritorialization in
the space of ideas so that we don't end
up in one cluster that's very cult-like
um and so Cults usually the they don't
they don't allow people to defect or
start competing Forks whereas we
encourage it
right